I know this guy he used to be a cop
you and your STAR Labs nerd better put
me back together you were dirty then and
you're dirty there's a long list of
people I want to toss them off rooftops
[Music]
when you're seeing this stuff like I'm
the beauty hey everybody we got a whole
bunch of flash to break down there's a
little bit more from next week's episode
episode 4 but we got our first look at
Katee Sackhoff if you remember I did a
video about her right before the season
started they announced that she was
going to be playing the blacksmith
character Amunet black from the comics
and I talked about her a little bit
during my episode 1 video because there
was a scene with her at the end with
killer frost who said I'm not going back
talking to that dirtbag who was also in
the bar with her so I'll explain that in
a second there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video this is that scene
with Caitlin where she talks about
Amunet black what have you been doesn't
matter really
Teli immune that I'm out you want to
quit snow doesn't look that way you do
what I mean it says for as long as she
tells you leave me alone freeze touch my
hand again and I'll freeze yourself
maybe some other parts to tell him yeah
I'm done
[Music]
don't let your beer get more so there's
like a really big preview from that
episode that I'll break down in a second
but just a circle back around to
elongated man stuff because he's gonna
be in the next couple of episodes
you see berry punch him in the face and
it just sinks right into his mouth
so it'll explain a little bit about how
his powers worked like he just has
complete elasticity it's a little bit
like mr. fantastic but they explained
that his character like the way that
Barry talks about him in the trailer
seems like kind of a dirtbag but I think
he'll wind up being one of the good
characters by the end of the season
just like last year HR started out
seeming like a dirtbag but by the end of
the season had sort of won everyone over
and everybody was really upset that he
died so hopefully they won't kill
elongated man after he redeems himself
before the finale but that's all next
week that'll sort of tee up his
abilities we'll find out what his
relation to the thinker is because the
way they're playing it in the trailer he
was also one of the people on that bus
but there might be some big twists to it
so just be prepared for that there are a
lot of you that have been asking about
the ralph Dib knee named drop during
flash season one they believe that he
died during the particle accelerator
explosion I know I heard a lot of people
that night people you don't even know
their names
Jake Davenport Darya Kim
Ralph dim man al Rothstein grant Emerson
Oh will Everett
they had to Kosta Ronnie Raymond so
either it's a retcon or they'll have a
different way of explaining it but just
remember that there were some metahumans
from back in season one that got powers
when the particle accelerator exploded
that we didn't learn about till much
much later so it'll be fun to see what
they do with the character but the
really cool stuff is episode 5 so the
week after that they're doing the mini
arrow crossover before the big four
night crossover and it's just called
girls night out they're doing Barry's
bachelor party in irises bachelorette
party so obviously they're building up
towards that big wedding but they're
introducing Amunet black Katee Sackhoff
scare achter and either we're gonna get
flashbacks - what happened to killer
frost after the finale when she was
working for Amunet black or she's going
to turn into killer frost during the
episode because in these promo pictures
she's wearing a new killer frost outfit
that looks like the outfit that she's
wearing during the four-night crossover
so it's like this blue jacket it looks
fantastic I loved her costume but it
sounds like after the finale she wound
up continuing to be killer frost because
she didn't take the serum so a while ago
I did that comic book video about the
thinker arc that Geoff Johns wrote from
the Wally West era the blacksmith was a
big character during that she ran this
big metahuman black market operation
called the network so it sounds like
that's also what she's doing on the TV
show she's just like a big boss like
Richard dragon on arrow is one of the
big bosses of the season it sounds like
that's the same thing with Katee
Sackhoff on the flash so the episode
description reads having received an
ominous threat from her old boss Amunet
Black Kalin fears that her pastime as
killer frost may be back to haunt her
the producers also explained she runs an
underground metahuman Fight Club that I
guess the girls go to watch in berry
winds up fighting in so that's sort of
how they cross over the storylines
because at some point you do have to
have the flash versus black Smith in the
episode so I don't know how many more
episodes this season Katee Sackhoff is
coming back for but it's probably this
one during the first half of the season
she might come back
the back half of the season if she gets
locked up in iron Heights prison like
they have that big prison break because
remember you have the 12 metahumans that
the thinker is trying to collect but in
the comics blacksmith never really
worked with the thinker so they were
just sort of two different big bosses
blacksmith was sort of the leader of the
Rogues in Central City while the thinker
had taken over a Keystone City so they
were like two separate entities we'll
see if they cross them over in the back
half though but the next big thing that
they just released was the description
for episode six which is right after the
blacksmith episode and it's going to be
sort of a Rick and Morty's style Council
of Rick's episode where they get a bunch
of different versions of Harrison wells
from the multiverse to form a think tank
so obviously I'll do a new video for
that when they release a new preview but
it'll be another week or two before we
see any footage from that if you haven't
watched Rick and Morty I would recommend
that you check it out most of it's on
Hulu they haven't put season three on
there yet but the council of ricks
episode is season 3 episode 7 lawyer is
a morty it's not fair you have no rights
and he's not a lawyer we just keep him
here because he's fun look at him go yes
slow Rick tall Morty did I graduate
eight this time yet anything's possible
tall Morty I'll add a link to that stuff
at the end of the video but a lot of you
have also requested that I do a video
for the Shazam announcement so in the
DCE youth they just cast the actor
that's going to play Billy Batson it's
going to be Zachary Levi so just imagine
the rock puts him on his workout plan
and they just go at each other in their
movie but they're also separately
developing a Black Adam spin-off movie
so there are a few questions about how
they're using these characters in the DC
EU and who else like Superman or the
other characters are going to cross over
into them so I'll do a video for that
next that should also post in a couple
hours
announce the next giveaway winner when I
post that video you can click here for
that Rick and Morty episode that I was
talking about and you can click here for
the last big Justice League trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight